il ya plusieurs joueurs de la lnh qui
vont sauter sur la glace ce dimanche à
ville mont royal
pourquoi les pour amasser des fonds pour
les jeunes et parmi ces joueurs là
christopher le temps des pingouins de
pittsburgh qui nous fait l'honneur de
venir me voir en studio ce matin bons
jours plus tôt après oui merci d'être là
ce matin vous impliquer beaucoup déjà là
auprès de la jeunesse avec une fondation
avec laquelle vous avez remis quoi 140
mille dollars jusqu'à maintenant
oui mais en fait ça fait deux ans puis
l'idée venue grâce au fait qu'on avait
gagné la coupe stanley puis à chaque
année j'aimais se remettait une certaine
cause dont les enfants
donc on en avait profité pour la coupe
stanley pour faire un match de hockey
on a fait deux équipes qui pèse une
damnation puis lé ghana mais la coupe
stanley des photos sur la glace puis on
avait remis les fonds à sainte justine
qui on s'était dit avec ça on devrait
faire un tournoi avec plusieurs équipes
puis la formule comme ça fait des petits
le piston est exactement ça avec eux ça
fait une belle formule de l'an passé est
un succès depuis cette année on
recommence la bonne nouvelle c'est que
vous avez pas gagné la coupe d'italie
cette année vous venez de vous visez 150
mille dollars pourquoi cette implication
auprès des jeunes pour cette cause là
particulièrement je pense que c'est
quelque chose que moi et ma femme on on
trouve très important c'est l'enfance la
jeunesse et les rêves toutes ces choses
là arrivent assez à cet âge là donc
d'essayer de donner la chance à ces
jeunes notamment une meilleure vie en
mer en france avant une chance de s'en
sortir c'est ce qui compose donc je suis
saint justin et d'autres organisations
aussi on y reçoit on a fait affaire avec
les petits déjeuners du québec qu'on
aura mis et le 21 59 qui est à l'ong la
fondation véro et louis également cette
vie nationale de théâtre comme ça on
aime ça bravo bravo on va se parler de
rock et quand même
christopher 14e saison bientôt avec les
pingouins les camps d'entraînement qui
vont commencer dans un mois environ mais
là vous êtes déjà à l'entrée de bakar
même votre nom a circulé beaucoup au
début de l'été pour un échange commandes
c'est un peu stressant je devrais que
c'est plus les gens qui tantôt quittant
par elle j'ai vu ton nom j'ai vu un
article non donc des fois c'est un peu
agaçant parce que il n'ya pas aucun
joueur dans les mercenaires qui
travaille pour son équipe qui donne pas
son sang pour s'appuie le petit
entendons nom qui veut dire que tournée
qui veut se débarrasser toi certains
pensent même effet longtemps
oui exactement mais quand j'ai commencé
ma cash avec jean j'entreprenais une
carrière dans une business
puis ces choses ne peuvent arriver donc
pour moi c'est ça la réussite à la rippe
mais c'est sûr que je suis bien là bas
cette chose-là est arrivé à un joueur
qu'on connaît bien ici à montréal alex
galchenyuk qui passent des coyotes au
pingouin est ce que vous pensez que ça
va être un bon environnement pittsburgh
pour relancer sa carrière
oui très bon environnement mais je pense
qu'il va avoir la chance de jouer avec
deux très bon joueur de centre qui on
sait que c'est un marqueur naturel ya
une ex ans a lancé beaucoup de talent
donc je pense avoir bien futé avec noter
que je vous entends sur le virage
jeunesse dans la vie nationale on en
parle beaucoup les recrues arrivées sont
rapides de bon gabarit vous avez 32 ans
sans doute plus de akid derrière vous
que devant qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces jeunes loups lucky qui viennent
brasser la cage suis pas contre mais
ceci je dis merci
mais j'ai pas convaincu que c'est la
chose à part au nom parce qu' un certain
niveau je te dirai pourrait on regarde
sa vue sauf que je pense que si je ne
devrais faire en sorte que ton ton
équipe soit mr plus rapide mais devrait
toujours tourneur noyau de joueurs plus
que d'expérience paix si tu regardes les
deux équipes de la coupe stanley deux
équipes qui on est beaucoup plus vieux
que leurs joueurs étoiles sont pas des
jeunes joueurs sont des joueurs d'être
en tête le monde les gens qui je parle
qui me pose c'est qu'elles sont là je
réponds cette réponse le chlore mais
c'est parce que tu es vieux mais j'ai
juste de répondre par les faits les
dernières coupes stanley qui ont été
gardien c'est tout des équipes que lors
les deux autres 30 ans ovechkin
backstrom les kings c'est les équipes
plus vieille notre équipe 1 équipe
pluvieux puis cette année on a la preuve
les deux équipes est en finale c'était
des équipes avec des lits de beaucoup
plus vieux que que des stars comme moi
je pars lundi on regarde tout vieux mais
je pense pour une bonne équilibre puis
enlevé trois coupes stanley vous c'est
quoi l'objectif 4e
non c'est quand un goûter a gagné la
coupe stanley de strange jusque là c'est
quelque chose que tu veux pas commencer
le plus avant la fin de carrière s'est
passée de la saison prochaine toujours
passionné
c'est beaucoup